ron you've been sweating in here all day
are you drinking any fluids yes
plenty
no you need to drink water usually i
take it neat but i will make an
exception in the name of health
last night i watched a movie with diane
and the girls
in which an orange fish is separated
from his father the children were
sniffling which i believe to be due to
the sad nature of the film
i was wrong
you need to take off those layers
rehydrate and go to the doctor thank you
for your concern i will be fine please
turn the thermostat up to 90 and leave
me alone ron this isn't safe i am a
grown man
i have had a cold before i need no help
so if you don't
mind
that seems about right
there is a crazy flu going around
lots of miserable dehydrated people with
high fevers and diarrhea and one of
those dehydrated high fevered miserable
people is april
who hates me
i want another nurse well there are none
we're stretched pretty thin right now
then i want a janitor they can do what
you do right
yep nurses and janitors are totally
interchangeable except no one dresses up
like a janitor when they want to be
[ __ ] i get the sense that maybe you're
angry at me for kissing andy no i'm not
what are you talking about that's crazy
and that you think it might be fun to
take it out on me
please don't do that
do i can't do anything
i'm sick
[Music]
my blankets are on the floor
[Music]
so
we've developed a revenue sharing
formula that will hopefully appeal to
most business owners leslie
go home you're sick i'm not sick it's
just allergies come on guys just let me
in there no you can't come in here
you're not coming in alyssa you you look
tired and you're all sweaty you look
tired and you're all sweaty all the time
what's your excuse you want to go there
jerry no fine i'm coming in donna
barricade the door now
ah come on just let me in
either go home or go back into
quarantine i'm not going home get out of
here leslie go home get the bricks
oh come on no no no no she's germin up
all my stuff aw yuck leslie
i do have
one question
hold on
oh my god
sorry andy are you getting sick it's flu
season again and i cannot get sick stock
up on kleenex don't touch your face
don't touch anything people are dropping
like flies we already have to quarantine
larry leslie i don't feel good can i
just work from home the tent is your
home now larry we already forwarded your
mail
leslie go home no i can't i can't go
home i have to get ready for the chamber
of secrets commerce if this meeting does
not go perfectly then the harvest
festival is gonna be over before it
began i cannot go home okay then who is
your doctor
anne's my doctor
and she's the most beautiful nurse in
the world come on
oh girl now i'm hot now it's really hot
okay well that's your fever
leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems
104.1 leslie you're dehydrated i'm
admitting you if i was sick could i do
this
what are you doing cartwheels
am i not doing them no leslie no back in
your tent sticky
i'm sorry but
chip mccann's manager called he has to
drop out no
okay we need all hands on deck but there
are no hands to be on deck because
everybody's at the winery okay andy you
and i need to handle this we need to be
operating at maximum capac
no no
damn it larry sorry okay i'm just gonna
double check your form here ron
you redacted all the information i
answered some of them for date of birth
you wrote springtime which is true
everything you write down is
confidential we need you to give real
answers
fine how many drinks of alcohol do you
consume a week one that's it one drink
one shelf
do you exercise yes lovemaking and
woodworking do you have any history of
mental illness in your family i have an
uncle who does yoga allergies cowardice
and weak-willed men
and hazelnuts sexual history epic and
private okay
i'm gonna go get your doctor he's a rude
brash jerk you'll love him
leslie and dr clipperton
wow man i
i'm so glad you guys are meeting it's
like worlds collide you know i love it
i want candy
what is he on morphine it's good stuff
leslie come here do you have any idea
how beautiful you are i'm serious you're
like
a flower or no like a snug bug or like a
a snugger doodle or something like that
we should just go for it you know
life
we have a ceremony we need to be at in
two hours is there anything that we can
do sorry i stay on you're not going
anywhere for at least a day
okay well i'll call mayor stice and
we'll reschedule the ceremony no this
town expects me to waste out i'm making
that speech and i'm simply going to
explain to the crowd that love is
everywhere and they have to surrender to
the flow of the universe you know
price's right is on i think
oh you remember staying home sick from
school
watching the presents right
oh god
hey ann what happened i just saw you a
few hours ago and you were fine
not like
damn you're fine but fine health-wise
my body has no fat to protect itself
from disease things happen very quickly
listen to me it's very important that
you replenish my body with electrolytes
after every involuntary loss of bodily
fluids oh boy my body tends to lose a
lot
of fluids
when it's sick
my brain is on fire i'm dying
well you definitely have the flu
oh my god
the microchip has been compromised
before you begin a few ground rules i
need you to explain everything you do
before you do it so i can determine
whether i will allow you oh
balsa wood you could at least use
mahogany
there's something occluding your ear
it's sawdust just blow
you've got strep throat running a
prescription for penicillin we'll have
the rest of your test results in about
20 minutes cholesterol not interested
good day
wish all patients were like that
it's really annoying when they ask
questions
i regret to inform you that someone in
this room has begun exhibiting symptoms
christopher traeger what a few months
ago the thought of an infectious disease
even hypothetical would have sent me
careening towards bummerville
but now
i am infected with the killer virus
and i feel fine
i vomited somewhere in this room
i don't remember where though
wait you might want to check that drawer
stop
pooping
you have to get up off the floor now as
far as my friends
nothing like a complete physical
breakdown to make a guy seem less
intimidating
i love blue
you